on fait partie d'une espèce humaine qui
a besoin de masculin ou féminin pour
mettre au monde un enfant c'est une
réalité incontestable et on pourra
jamais la changé depuis quelques jours
une campagne du planning familial
mettant en scène un homme enceint fait
polémique pourquoi est-elle
problématique selon vous cette campagne
est un vrai scandale c'est une véritable
dépossession de la maternité des femmes
s'il ya de spécifique aux femmes c'est à
dire la différence des sexes c'est quand
même la possibilité de faire des enfants
donc on a affaire ici à un détournement
de la puissance maternelle des femmes au
profit d'une idéologie de
l'autodétermination de l'identité de
genre et ce qui est grave c'est que
cette idéologie elle nie complètement
l'aspect biologique du corps c'est à
dire les fonctions les fonctions ce
qu'on appelait autrefois les fonctions
naturelles qu'est ce qu'on voit sur la
fiche une femme née biologiquement
femmes et qui s'identifie comme un homme
elle a gardé donc son utérus à côté
d'elle il ya aussi un homme jeudi à côté
d'elle je devrais dire à côté de lui
c'est la victoire totale du genre
masculin qui est célébrée par le
planning on veut nous faire croire qu'un
homme peut-être ans non c'est pas vrai
c'est une femme qui est enceinte elle a
toujours son utérus et elle peut donner
donner la vie ce sont les femmes qui qui
qui met les enfants au monde sont pas
les hommes
cette différence là elle existe c'est un
fait biologique et on peut pas aller
contre les faits or l'idéologie trans
justement consiste à imposer l'idéologie
sur la réalité biologique des corps il
n'y a pas de coupure entre l'esprit et
le corps donc on l'a on est dans
l'idéologie du transhumanisme cdd on va
construire des corps cette affiche est
elle le signe d'une dérive de
l'association il est très important le
planning ils font un travail formidable
mais c'est le problème de la direction
ce qui se passe c'est une pénétration à
l'intérieur d'une association qui
fonctionne très bien de force
destructrice le planning je voulais à
procéder par étapes la première étape ça
a été
la prise de pouvoir des
intersectionnelle avec vidéo logis dur
le ter relativisme culturel c'est-à-dire
que les lois ne sont pas les mêmes selon
les pays selon les religions selon les
moeurs donc c'est une contestation de
l'universalisme féministe qu'est ce que
c'est que l'universalisme et féministe
les femmes ont toutes les mêmes droits
alors vous avez aussi une deuxième
atteinte à l'universalisme c'est à
travers le mot laïcité dans les années
2000 18 qui a eu une tentative d'en
remettre en question la laïcité de
mouvement et de retirer le mot laïcité
de la chartre du planning la ministre
des droits des femmes a menacé de
supprimer les subventions donc elles ont
été obligés de reculer le planning
familial a publié un lexique trans qui
est une véritable police du langage il
ne désire faut dire ça il faut pas dire
ça etc mais attention la police du
langage elle est faite contre les femmes
et contre le mot femme n'est pas du tout
fait contre les armées contre le mob par
exemple il parle aussi de sexe a signé à
la naissance comme si les médecins
d'user toi tu seras un homme et toi tu
seras une film en fait c'est un sexe qui
est constaté à la naissance oui comment
joue l'idéologie donc vous avez vraiment
une dépossession à la fois du mot femme
n'est aussi de la féminité au profit
d'une caricature stéréotypée du féminin
ce contre quoi les féministes se sont
battus depuis 50 ans au lieu de lutter
de changer les mentalités de lutter
contre les stéréotypes il les renforce
la ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
isabelle rome a apporté son soutien à
l'association accusons l'extrême droite
d'attiser les ailes qu'en pensez vous ce
n'est pas du tout l'extrême droite qui
attaquent moi je m'attaque je ne suis
pas d'extrême droite et critiques
viennent du féminisme il ya beaucoup de
féministes qui critiquent cette affiche
c'est vraiment de la mauvaise foi de les
qualifier de d'extrême droite c'est
refuser le débat refuser le dialogue
vous savez la tactique utilisée en
général c'est de traiter de transforme
toutes les personnes qui veulent
discuter vous êtes tout de suite ce
pigment teasé de homophobes et
transphobes lesbophobes tout ce que vous
voulez c'est quand même très grave et
c'est le rôle du gouvernement de
favoriser les débats démocratiques
je pense pas que la société elle va
pouvoir nier éternellement la vérité
biologique parce que les chromosomes x
et les chromosomes y ont peut pas
manipuler les chromosomes c'est le
mystère de la vie justement c'est ça qui
est intéressant on fait partie d'une
espèce humaine qui a besoin de masculin
ou de féminin pour mettre au monde un
enfant c'est une réalité incontestable
et on pourra jamais la changer et c'est
une la grandeur de notre de l'espèce
humaine d'être bisexuelle
c'est pas un problème le problème c'est
quand vous avez 1 6 qui domine sur
l'autre donc c'est un problème culturel
et là on est en train d'attaquer la
biologie comme si c'était la biologique
était responsable de la domination
masculine
c'est ça qui est grave